was im nordrhein westfälischen herford 4
bürgerinnen und bürgern passiert ist
hört sich an wie ein ganz schlechter
scherz in corona zeiten
die einen gehen durch den stadtpark
spazieren die anderen führen ihre hunde
gassi
sie begegnen sich zufällig und kassieren
dafür dann allein knöllchen pro person
satte 230 euro unfassbar
ich habe mir erst mal gedacht das kann
doch jetzt nicht wahr sein dass ich da
so viel geld zahlen soll
für eine kurze unterhaltung war
natürlich total ersetzen hat sich
gefragt warum nur weil wir haben
eigentlich nichts verkehrt gemacht
anfang april ist dennis marx mit seinem
welpen samy im herforder erwiesen park
unterwegs
zufällig kommt linda müller mit ihrem
hund bentley vorbei die hunde tollen
herum herrchen und frauchen gucken zu
selbstverständlich in korrektem corona
abstand wenig später kommen zwei
bekannte vorbei man begrüßt sich über
zehn bis 15 meter bei einem kurzen
plausch halten alle natürlich die
vorgeschriebenen abstände zueinander ein
immer wesentlich mehr als der
mindestabstand von zwei metern nichts
böses geht einfach nur eine runde durch
und parks zum abendspaziergang weil man
ja sonst nicht mehr raus darf und dann
kommt auf einmal so was denn wie aus dem
nichts tritt das ordnungsamt auf den
plan
für die vier herren vom amt ist das
keine zufällige begegnung im park
sondern dies ist eine illegale
ansammlung nach paragraf 12 der korona
schutzverordnung die betroffenen sind
fassungslos bauernfängerei ein interview
lehnt die stadt herford ab schriftlich
heißt es zum genannten fall werden wir
uns nicht äußern da es ein laufendes
verfahren ist für die betroffenen ist
das verhalten der behörde völlig
unverhältnismäßig ich bin mir definitiv
bis heute in keiner schuld bewusst was
dran
deshalb hatten dennis marx jetzt einen
rechtsanwalt eingeschaltet
herr marx will von einem gericht klären
lassen ob er für das gassi gehen und
eine zufällige begegnung im grünen
tatsächlich
bestraft werden darf